dodgers winners of 16 of their last 19
games eight in a row here at dodger
stadium another one-two pitch calhoun
swings and misses at an elevated
fastball for the first down of the nine
already back home with the 2-1 pitch
it's a slider that's lifted to left
center field
pollock with a call and the catch to
finish off a one two three first for
walker buehler now powell could get a
head start here in a scoreless first
inning there goes pollock
on the ground to first an easy play for
christian walker the dodgers get one hit
they leave that man and after one no
score dodger city laid off man in
scoring position 0-2 pitch
he struck him out but it kicks away from
smith and rojas will reach bueller's got
to cover home to make sure peralta
doesn't come into score nonetheless it
puts runners at first and third and
brings up nick ahmed first and third one
gone a 3-2 pitch
and a fly ball to right center field
bets will cut over and make the catch
here's his throw home it's up the line
it's over smith but peralta's retreating
up the second goes rojas
and it's still nothing nothing the set
in the 1-1
varsity pops it up into right
lux goes back makes the call in the
catch and buehler is able to pitch
around the traffic in the second big
crowds play two games including night
games
sky high pop up
center field ponic having a hard time
finding it now he does and he makes the
catch
must have been hit up above the lights
[Music]
oh what a lonely feeling that had to be
for a moment
he said i can't see we know
we saw that bases empty two gone here's
rojas luther digs back into the glove
winds and deals a payoff and rojas takes
strike three back-to-back fastballs at
97. that's going to do it bueller
retires the side in order he's got four
strikeouts in the game here's chris
taylor grounded the third first time up
fastball right by him second strikeout
for zach and he's through four with
bueller no score in la on the d-backs
radio network in a scoreless fifth
inning back to the top and cole calhoun
1-1 offering calhoun pulls it to first
muncie's got it it was on a bounce but
it didn't matter no score gallon and
bueller going head-to-head the pitch
again and a swing of the miss reels down
strikes gallons fan four here in five
innings third consecutive one two three
inning and he sit down ten in a row so
one loud out here to start the six
that'll bring up walker two and two on
christian walker
hits a fly ball deep to left field
taylor backing up at the wall get out of
here
christian walker another dodger stadium
home run that's the fifth of his career
and the d-backs strike first in la good
hacks at high fastball early in the
at-bat but ultimately gets a breaking
ball that stayed on that inner part of
the plate christian walker launching one
into the la night to give the d-backs a
one-nothing lead gallon has completed
seven innings in three of his last four
starts this has become a recurrent theme
now
that changeup has been tremendous here
as of late 11 straight set down by zach
allen
swing and a miss another change up for
zach gatlin who has struck out six now
just down in order for the fourth
consecutive inning that's 13 in a row
he's set down
about to throw pitch number 90 in the
ball game full count three and
two another change up but another
strikeout that's seven for gallon
i mean he's got to go on tonight
lift the curve ball up a little bit var
show to the warning track and he's got
it and just a handful of pitches thrown
in the seventh
by zach gallop
hard to third escobar they get one
cattell
turns it the double play
slowly developing five four three
cattell martin gets it over to walker
and quickly two ounces in the eighth
punches that one the other way here
comes peralta david's got it on a
sliding grab
and that gets us to the ninth inning
here's bats one nothing one gone ninth
inning mookie bets
hits a fly ball to center field it sends
varshall back he's at the wall and it's
tied
mookie back saves the day with a solo
shot of the ninth inning
his 12th home run of the year
the dodgers are pulled even at 1-1
and now the diamondbacks will run out
have the bases full for christian walker
he walked in a run janssen wanted that
one looked like it was on the corner
here comes varsho and it's 2-1
diamondbacks two down now for eduardo
escobar
that's what jackson was trying to go he
missed his spot but got a swing and a
miss for strike three
tying around his second 10th inning 1-1
pitch
lays this bunt down garrett going to
third and he throws it wildly this game
is tied and the winning run is in
scoring position in the blink of an eye
and up comes will smith with one away
two on pitch
that is going to do it the dodgers do
just enough tonight to win it three two
and ten innings